هذا هو السطح 2 ، هذا المنتج هو
السطح ، ما مدى جمال
هذا المنتج ، ليس فقط بسبب
الأجهزة ليس فقط بسبب الأجهزة ،
لا لا لا ، ولكن لأنني منتج ، يمكنك
أن تكون عليه ، وهو مناسب ممتاز ، ينهي
النحافة الجميلة  لا تصدق
كل المواقف القابلة للتكيف التي رأيتها على
السطح الجديد ممكّنة هنا من خلال
نفس المفصلة 362 5c 365 درجة ، حيث
تجتمع الشاشتان جنبًا إلى جنب مقاس 5.6 بوصة
معًا بطريقة قوية بشكل لا يصدق
لتمكين كل موقف من
المواقف التي تراها هناك ونحن
الشراكة مع Google
لتجميع أفضل ما في Android معًا في
منتج واحد يجمع بين روح التصميم الفريد
والابتكار الذي يجلبه السطح مع
كل تطبيق فردي في نظام Android
البيئي ، هذه هي التكنولوجيا التي تدفع الصناعة وتقنيتها تدفع
الإمكانيات